est ce que vous dites c'est en train de
manger quoi vous dire que les jaunes et
m'ont mise en garde est secouée jouer je
le dis aux téléspectateurs benhaim est
devenu roi à chaque fois vous l'appelez
mon frère elle en train de lire un
bouquin ça va tu l'appelles le jeu monte
inacio nez sur quoi le club des cinq
on dormait pas ensemble y avait un lit
et wade dans le landeau à côté un doigt
d'honneur qui avait le geste préféré de
série d'un lula
non pas du tout c'est ma main dans ta
gueule raconte l'histoire c'est vrai je
serai qu'à copains on est en vacances on
est avec des copains du genre du jeune
fille qu'on vient de connaître un copine
et je sais que moi je suis avec deux
copains et je sais qu'il y en a un on a
joué au foot la veille dès qu'il a un
ongle noir là le gros ongles noirs et je
sais que c'est relou cantus in une meuf
ha non seulement sur la plage c'est
toujours à port aux loups donc je le
vois et je sais que il ya des meufs qui
sont la roche-aux-fées la fédé rigolade
charrie un peu tout le monde et à un
moment je sais que je vois que lui il a
son qui dans le sable et la jetée de
meuf ouais j'ai une des vols dit voilà
sortir avec un mec qui a un accident de
la vie toi dis quoi
ben c'est pas un mec qui a un beau jour
un ongles noirs et là il sort son pied
est là bien sûr rigolade et finalement
la base grâce à moi c'est lui qui l'a
pas fait chaud
[Musique]
embrasse moi va sinon ouais bah ça veut
bien voilà
[Applaudissements]
vous avez une présence ah oui car vous
allez avoir une absence de questions sur
son en france la question
[Musique]
la question qui continue
et a10 près combien d'hommes sont
satisfaits de la taille de leurs gigot
bigouden on veut faire un exercice
hausse ensemble ah non non le plus
gaulois des parcs d'attractions sera
ouvert à noël c'est la première fois
qu'ils ouvrent d'habitude à noël dernier
évidemment dehors pas de potion magique
train du tout tu dis que j'irai au parc
astérix pendant noël
je vais aller au parc astérix oui voilà
avec mes enfants je vous le dis j'ai à
nouveau avec des enfants des autres mois
seul l'avenir avec moi c'est bienvenu
alors je lui qui veut pas voir ma gueule
c'est pas bien celui qui veut rester
chez lui à boire de la potion magique
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rêver
enfin
[Musique]
merci super
au café sa bande à vis tu as ta place
canivez calais
il est très sympathique dwayne johnson
et kevin hart aussi le très sympa il m'a
dit à i want to baisse minime des yoyos
rabah noël soit en sial à huy le 19
décembre direct il va y avoir des duplex
partout on va faire une émission le fou